Donc petit rappel, les thèmes de cette leçon c'est les baptêmes du croyant proprement dit.
Je sais que pour certains c'est peut-être une leçon qui ne porte pas encore des défis pour vous,
surtout pour ceux qui sont nouveaux dans la foi, de manière parfois très naturelle.
On va se laisser instruire selon l'église dans laquelle on a été converti,
sans se poser trop de questions par rapport à certains points doctrinales
qu'on a tout simplement appris en fait.
Donc par exemple, on n'est pas tout à fait au courant qu'il y a certaines ères dans la théologie
où nous pouvons avoir des accords.
Donc bien sûr que quand on contemple la plupart des églises, on voit aussi tant des différences.
On peut se demander même si Dieu est un peu schizophrénique,
car il y a beaucoup, beaucoup de différences qui ne sont pas en fait légitimes.
Donc pour la plupart, je dirais, des différences entre les églises,
nous n'avons pas en fait des possibilités bibliques pour soutenir.
Et donc si nous considérons que la Bible, elle est la seule règle de foi et des conduites,
c'est par elle qu'on doit apprendre, par exemple, la conception du baptême
ou la conception des comment les déroulements d'un culte doivent avoir lieu.
Il y a beaucoup d'activités qui se passent dans certaines églises au moment du culte
qui ne devraient pas se passer car la Bible est très claire par rapport aux choses qui doivent être là
ou ne doivent pas être là.
Quand on pense par exemple à la gouvernance de l'église
ou qui doit prêcher la parole, qui peut être pasteur par exemple,
même si les églises pratiquent de manière différente
et que certaines considèrent que les femmes puissent prêcher par exemple,
la Bible n'est pas en silence à cet égard.
Elle est très claire à cet égard.
Donc il y a beaucoup de différences d'églises
que nous n'allons jamais trouver des bases bibliques pour justifier.
Par contre, il y a quelques points doctrinales
qui pour plus que dans leur essence,
nous soyons rassurés que la Bible est claire
et par là nous ne pouvons bien sûr pas justifier toutes les différences possibles
mais nous devons reconnaître que par rapport à certains accidents
ou certains éléments plutôt périphériques de ces conceptions,
nous pouvons trouver des désaccords.
Car la Bible est suffisante pour décrire ce qu'elle est plus importante
à propos de ces doctrines
mais elle n'est pas exhaustive
pour que nous puissions réclamer
une position biblique conclusive
à certains égards.
Donc pour exemplifier,
si nous pensons par exemple
à la fin des temps,
nous avons la possibilité
nous devons être d'accord
sur ce qui est essentiel.
Jésus-Christ va revenir
pour juger les vivants et les morts.
Il nous va ramener à la gloire.
Nous serons glorifiés.
Ceux qui sont morts seront ressuscités.
Pour un jugement soit pour la vie éternelle,
soit pour la condamnation éternelle.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est que les plus importants et essentiels
doivent être communs à toutes les positions.
Par contre,
quand est-ce qu'il est Christ réviant ?
Est-ce qu'il va exercer sur terre un royaume littéral ?
Est-ce qu'il est déjà en train d'exercer ces royaumes
de manière spirituelle ?
Les mille ans, etc.
Donc il y a plusieurs aspects secondaires,
si on peut dire comme ça,
par rapport à la fin des temps,
qui sont des théologiens également pieux,
également responsables,
également capables,
si on peut dire comme ça,
dans leur méthode d'interprétation biblique.
Ils se sont mis en désaccord.
Donc certains aspects sur la fin des temps
peuvent permettre des désaccords.
Les baptêmes,
c'est une autre doctrine
où des hommes également pieux,
également capables,
ont été en désaccord au long de l'histoire.
Donc,
ce n'est pas forcément à propos
de la définition essentielle du baptême,
mais c'est par rapport à certaines
conceptions plutôt secondaires.
Elles sont importantes,
mais elles ne sont pas en train de définir
l'essence de ce qu'est les baptêmes.
Et donc,
quand on considère,
par exemple,
les possibilités
ou les conceptions différentes
à propos du baptême
au long de l'histoire de l'Église,
nous sommes devant
des déroutes
qui vont compromettre
même la signification du baptême.
Donc, par exemple,
si nous pensons à la conception catholique du baptême
ou à la conception louterraine du baptême,
et parfois même
la conception méthodiste du baptême,
elles peuvent être compromises
car dans leur compréhension,
les baptêmes,
ils peuvent communiquer
une plus grande
ou une plus faible
mesure des grâces
automatiques.
Qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là ?
Pour les catholiques,
les baptêmes,
lorsqu'un enfant est né
et qu'il est baptisé,
les baptêmes,
ils communiquent de soi-même
une grâce salvatrice.
Donc,
ceux qui sont baptisés
sont sauvés
selon la conception catholique,
à moins que plus tard
dans leur vie,
ils commettent un péché
qu'ils considèrent mortel
et à partir de là,
ils peuvent perdre leur salut,
conception qui n'est pas non plus biblique,
et ils doivent retravailler
pour réconquérir leur salut.
Donc, ça,
c'est la conception catholique.
La conception louterraine,
ce n'est pas forcément
que cette mesure des grâces
qui a communiqué automatiquement
au baptême
sauve la personne,
mais c'est comme si
elle communiquait
une portion des grâces
qui peut habiliter
cette personne plus tard
à choisir ou non
pour sa foi.
Et donc,
c'est comme si cette grâce
et la conception méthodiste
étaient un peu dans la même direction,
c'est comme s'il y avait
vraiment quelque chose
de concret
qui a communiqué
de manière mystique,
mystérieuse,
une mesure des grâces
en contribuant au salut
à partir du moment
où l'enfant est baptisé.
Donc,
à partir de là,
nous,
en tant que protestants,
réformés,
et pour plus,
qu'on ait beaucoup de choses
en commun avec la notion
du salut louterraine,
nous ne pouvons pas être d'accord
avec cette pratique du baptême.
Et donc là,
en fait,
à partir du moment
où dans notre conception
du baptême,
le baptême communique
une grâce de soi-même,
il l'opère de soi-même
de manière automatique,
il devient un instrument
religieux
superstitieux
comme si
les choses matérielles
pouvaient nous bénir.
C'est un peu comme font
certaines églises
évangéliques aujourd'hui
avec l'eau bénie
ou l'huile loin
ou quelque chose comme ça.
L'idée
que ces instruments
matériels
puissent bénir
de soi-même.
Et donc,
par contre,
quand on considère
les possibilités
d'entre les églises
réformées,
nous arrivons
à une définition
commune
et essentielle
du baptême
entre,
par exemple,
les presbytériens,
les congrégationnels
et même
les baptistes
réformés.
Et là,
j'ai dit vraiment
de manière très claire
quand on pense
à la conception
essentielle
du baptême.
Donc,
si on pense
aux églises
presbytériennes,
si on pense
aux églises
congrégationnelles
et les églises
baptistes réformées,
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
des communs
dans notre conception
essentielle du baptême.
Nous affirmons tous
que les baptêmes,
ils n'oppèrent pas
de soi-même
une grâce salvatrice,
qu'il est un symbole
d'une réalité
spirituelle
et qu'il sert
pour sceller
une réalité
spirituelle
qui a les saluent.
Donc,
cette conception,
c'est quelque chose
qu'on a étudié ensemble
quand on a commencé
à étudier sur les baptêmes.
La fonction
du baptême,
c'est
de représenter
quelque chose
de spirituel
et de sceller.
Par contre,
là où on va diverger
des congrégationnelles
et des présbytériens,
c'est
qui doit
se soumettre
au baptême ?
Qui,
l'église,
est commissionnée,
commandée
et baptisée
et qui est la personne
qui est apte
pour se faire baptiser ?
Et donc,
c'est à partir de là
où nous allons voir
la divergence
critique
car
dans la conception
baptiste,
la nôtre,
réformée
du baptême,
la définition
elle va s'étendre
aussi
à sa pratique.
Donc,
nous allons considérer
par exemple
que c'est plus cohérent
de faire usage
de ces symboles
de la nouvelle alliance
exclusivement
à ceux qui sont
déjà dans la foi.
Et,
de manière très essentielle
et superficielle
car on va
aller plus en profondeur,
notre argument
basique
c'est que
c'est incohérent
de chercher
à faire usage
d'un saut
de quelque chose
qui vise à sceller
une relation avec Dieu.
Par exemple,
si on pense au mariage,
on met la bague
de mariage
une fois
qu'on s'est marié.
Donc,
la réalité
de la relation
doit précéder
on va dire comme ça
la formalisation
ou de sceller
cette relation.
Et c'est
un moment
d'expérience
réjouissante
pour celui
qui est baptisé.
Il est conscient
de cette alliance
lorsqu'elle a lieu.
Et donc,
c'est dans notre conception
qu'on appelle
credo baptiste,
c'est-à-dire
ceux qui croivent
sont baptisés,
tous ceux qui croivent
sont baptisés
et qu'est-ce
qui croivent
sont baptisés.
Et,
on va réclamer,
bon,
si vous définissez
les baptêmes
comme un saut,
ok,
et si vous définissez
les baptêmes
comme
un symbole
d'une réalité
spirituelle,
ce n'est pas
aussi cohérent
que ces symboles
et que ces sauts
soient pratiqués
lorsque la réalité
qu'ils visent
sceller et représenter
n'est pas encore là.
Et donc là,
c'est la divergence
principale
entre les baptistes
et les pédobaptistes,
on veut dire comme ça,
ou ceux qui baptisent
les enfants.
Des questions jusqu'ici ?
Oui.
C'est quoi la différence
entre les congrégations
et les baptistes
et les baptistes ?
Ok,
donc les églises
congrégationnelles,
elles ont une gouvernance
similaire aux églises
baptistes,
c'est-à-dire nous sommes
gouvernés par la
congrégation,
ce sont les anciens
qui vont instruire
bibliquement la communauté,
mais c'est la communauté
qui prend la décision.
Ok ?
Par contre,
les congrégationalistes,
ils baptisent les enfants.
Donc,
ils sont en intercession
quelque part
entre les baptistes
réformés
et les presbytériens.
D'accord ?
Donc,
les presbytériens,
c'est les collèges
d'anciens,
des pasteurs
qui font les décisions
et pas forcément
toute la communauté,
même s'ils sont élus
par la communauté.
Et de l'autre côté,
nous sommes du côté
congrégationnel
pour la gouvernance
d'église,
mais nous ne sommes
ni du côté
des congrégationnels
ni des presbytériens
quand ça concerne
la pratique du baptême.
On a la même
conception essentielle,
mais nous n'avons pas
la même pratique
du baptême.
Ok ?
Ok.
Donc,
je vais avancer.
C'est une leçon
qui est la plus longue,
je pense.
Il faut vraiment
que je sois accroché
à mes noix,
sinon je vais pouvoir
m'éritarder.
Et donc,
première chose
à observer,
comme je viens
de vous dire,
c'est que
la dernière leçon,
la déclaration
essentielle,
c'est,
de manière très positive,
on a présenté
notre position
au pied de baptiste.
Et quand on a décidé
de faire cette leçon 3,
c'était surtout
en prenant en considération
des personnes
qui nous pouvons recevoir,
des églises
qui baptisent des enfants.
Et donc là,
c'est important
de remarquer,
une présentation positive
a déjà été faite,
et maintenant,
on va plutôt
éclairer,
en fait,
pourquoi nous avons
la conviction
que même si on peut
avoir de la communion
avec les congrégationalistes
ou les presbytériens,
nous ne pouvons,
et même dans nos conférences,
dans nos églises,
ils peuvent venir prêcher
sans aucun problème.
Par contre,
notre conviction
par rapport au baptême
ne permet pas,
en fait,
qu'on vive une vie
d'église ensemble,
car nos convictions
sont particulières
à cet égard.
Et donc là,
en fait,
nous,
si nous recevons
des personnes
qui viennent des milieux
pédobaptistes,
c'est très important
qu'ils soient convaincus
de nos convictions bibliques
ou au moins qu'ils comprennent
nos convictions bibliques
et qu'ils comprennent
pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas
accepter en tant que membre
des personnes
qui ne sont pas baptisées
après leur conversion.
OK ?
Donc la réponse essentielle,
c'est que ceux
qui sont baptisés,
pardon,
que ceux qui sont croyants
et tous ceux
qui sont croyants
doivent se faire baptiser.
Et donc,
la première chose
qu'il faut considérer
quand on discute
ces choses-là,
c'est l'impact
de nos expériences
et de nos traditions
sur nos positions doctrinales.
Ça, c'est quelque chose
de très important
et même dans la Bible,
on voit ça.
Donc,
indépendamment
de lever les drapeaux
d'un côté
ou de l'autre,
c'est important
de remarquer
tout simplement
dans la Bible
que l'impact
de l'environnement
où on a été élevé,
où nous nous sommes convertis,
peut-être là
où on a été baptisé,
sans que
ce qu'on a reçu
en tant qu'instruction
ait été
basé
de manière claire,
explicite
et profonde
dans les écritures.
C'est un impact
où l'habitude
ou la tradition
ou même
l'expérience personnelle
peuvent jouer
beaucoup
pour une résistance,
pour changer
des positions
si jamais
on pourrait être
convaincu
par les écritures.
Et donc ça c'est important
car parfois
il y a toujours
une tentation
de l'orgueil
de garder les traditions
ou même
de garder les relations
parfois
avec la famille
même,
parfois c'est dur
car la famille
ne va pas vouloir
accepter
qu'on se fasse baptiser
car pour eux
ils sont convaincus,
ils ont été élevés
comme ça,
c'était valable,
c'était un vrai baptême,
etc.
Donc on a déjà vécu
ce type d'expérience
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
lorsque Jésus vient
et qu'il dit
qu'il est venu
apporter l'épée
et non la paix
c'était notamment
à cause du fait
qu'il y avait
une tradition religieuse
très lourde
à son époque
et dans cette tradition
religieuse très lourde
les pères,
les parents
n'allaient pas accepter
ceux qui reconnaîtraient
l'Écrit comme Messie
par rapport
à leur tradition
juive religieuse
et ça c'est une chose
qui peut rester longtemps
dans nos cœurs
si nous ne faisons pas attention
peu importe
quelle soit l'enfance
doctrinale
qu'on a derrière
et ça peut marcher
des deux côtés
voilà pourquoi
le plus important
c'est de considérer
quand on pense
aux expériences
personnelles
aux traditions
et aux transitions
je voulais dire un mot
par rapport aux transitions
et ça c'est tout simplement
en observant
les personnes
qui ont pu changer
des positions
à cet égard
ils ont changé
par exemple
d'une position
pédobaptiste
envers une position
baptiste
comme c'était mon cas
ou ceux qui ont changé
d'une position
baptiste
envers une position
pédobaptiste
ce qui va ressortir
dans les expériences
des personnes
sont deux choses
c'est soit
l'impact
d'une expérience
existentielle
qu'est-ce que je veux dire
par là
par exemple
les baptistes
peuvent avoir
une tendance
car ils vont assumer
aussi comme les presbytériens
doivent le faire
mais nous allons mettre
plus en face
sur le fait
que nos enfants
ne peuvent être baptisés
que lorsqu'ils seront convertis
et des fois
on va mener une relation
on peut arriver
à mener une relation
très dure
envers nos enfants
et avoir des attentes
très élevées
pour les considérer
convertis
et certains
enfants
qui sont élevés
de cette manière
ils peuvent se plaindre
en fait
de ne jamais avoir été
encouragés
d'une manière
un peu plus optimiste
envers leur foi
car aujourd'hui
ils sont dans la maturité
ils regardent à l'aïa
ils considèrent
qu'ils étaient déjà chrétiens
mais ils ont été
plutôt encouragés
à être toujours
dans la méfiance
envers leur propre foi
et ça peut être nuisible
et c'est un risque possible
ok
et donc ces personnes là
lorsqu'ils auront
leurs propres enfants
ils peuvent avoir
une tendance
à embrasser
la position pédobaptiste
afin d'être un peu plus optimiste
envers leur salut
ok
de l'autre côté
c'est l'inverse
qui peut se passer
des parents
qui peuvent devenir
un peu plus relaxés
un peu moins diligents
pour trouver les signes
et les exhortations
envers la conversion
car ils peuvent se reposer
quelque part
dans une espèce
de confiance
sur le fait
que comme il a été baptisé
et qu'il va agrandir
dans cet environnement
il va se convertir
et donc là
c'est juste pour vous partager
les deux convictions
des baptêmes
ne justifient pas
un manque d'équilibre
ou des responsabilités
à ces mêmes égards
mais c'est juste
que l'expérience
parfois qui joue
pour un changement
des positions
n'est pas forcément
instruite par les écritures
mais elle est plutôt
elle ressort
en fait
d'une expérience
qui a été plutôt traumatisée
et ils veulent changer
les choses
envers leurs enfants
et c'est pas
la bonne manière
de traiter
ces choses
une autre remarque
qu'on peut faire
c'est que parfois
ceux qui vont
mettre l'emphase
sur un changement
de position
plutôt
envers la considération
si on peut dire
comme ça
pédobaptiste
ils vont mettre
beaucoup de poids
sur l'argument
de l'histoire
de l'église
et particulièrement
l'histoire
de la réforme
donc on va montrer
par exemple
comment à partir
de la réforme
on n'a jamais remis
en question
la question du baptême
et donc si nous sommes
véritablement connectés
à la réforme
nous
voilà
donc c'est une emphase
une espèce
d'influence possible
du fait
qu'un vivant
dans une génération
qui est tellement
déconnectée
de l'histoire
qui vit énormément
d'innovation
ces personnes
vont chercher
dans des repères
plutôt historiques
c'est qu'il y a
plutôt bien
quelque chose
qui puisse
lui donner
un peu plus
de conviction
par rapport à ça
et par contre
même si
l'histoire
est toujours
une bonne manière
en fait
de retrouver
les convictions
c'est pas forcément
une précision historique
assez équilibrée
car quand on va
revenir au premier siècle
on a des évidences
du crédo baptême
dans plusieurs églises
et aussi
quelques évidences
du pédobaptain
du baptême
d'enfant
dans quelques églises
et donc
les faits
qu'à partir
de la réforme
on n'a pas
fait une réforme
aussi profonde
d'objectif
à cet aspect
ne veut pas dire
qu'à l'origine
les choses
étaient comme ça
une autre chose
qui est importante
à remarquer
c'est que
si vous remarquez
dans l'histoire
de l'église
de la réforme
quand on est
dans les 16e siècle
avec les réformateurs
Calvin,
Leuter etc
les plus grandes questions
n'étaient pas forcément
la gestion de l'église
et la pratique
des ordonnances
en soi
c'était la définition
essentielle
des ordonnances
d'abord
donc là par exemple
avec la restauration
de fait
que l'éucharistie
ne devient pas
la santé
les corps du Christ
mais que ces choses là
sont un symbole
et sont
donc c'est par là
qu'on est en train
de redéfinir
l'essence des choses
mais ce qui était prioritaire
c'était surtout
la sotériologie
c'est à dire
la doctrine à propos
du salut
la justification
par la foi
etc etc
quand on arrive
à la génération
des puritans
c'est là
où on va commencer
à faire une réforme
plus large
de toutes les pratiques
ecclésiales
donc les réformateurs
c'est surtout
la foi
les saluts
la suffisance
des écritures
etc
et quand on arrive
aux puritans
c'est la deuxième
et troisième génération
après la réforme
c'est à partir de là
que nous allons avoir
cette réforme
et les baptistes
vont naître
dans ces contextes
très vite en fait
avec la réforme
nous avons déjà
cette proposition
des réformes
aussi
de la compréhension
du baptême
pour ne pas baptiser
les enfants
donc depuis l'époque
de la réforme
depuis très proche
de l'époque de la réforme
nous avons déjà ça
et dès les origines
donc c'est important
d'avoir cette perspective
historique
à cet égard
il faut qu'on avance
et donc il y a
ces poids
des expériences personnelles
des traditions
etc
la chose qu'on doit apprendre
c'est que nos convictions
doivent être issues
avant tout
des écritures
ok
nous devons considérer
l'expérience
l'histoire
mais nous devons considérer
avant tout
la Bible
et donc la Bible
est
ou doit être
la source
des plus grands arguments
envers nos convictions
à cet égard
quelle est
la hiérarchie
des priorités
à cet égard
par exemple
c'est des savoirs
qui pour plus
qu'on doit avoir
des convictions particulières
par rapport au baptême
nous devons savoir
et connaître aussi
quelles sont les priorités
pour l'erreur des dieux
donc pourquoi Paul
il a demandé
que Timothée
soit circoncis
et en même temps
que Tite
ne soit pas
circoncis
donc c'est très intéressant
quand on va étudier Galate
Paul est en train
d'enseigner clairement
cette circoncision
n'a plus
sens d'existence
Christ a tout accompli
c'est la circoncision
de cœur
qui est maintenant
un père
dans l'église
mais par là
en fait
il a
il a demandé
en fait
que Timothée
soit circoncis
pourquoi
la réalité
c'est que
les priorités
des stratégies
d'évangélisation
ont fait
que ça soit
un recours
légitime
stratégique
car cela
n'était pas
en train
de compromettre
la conception
du salut
pourquoi
un Galate
il va réclamer
que personne
ne peut demander
de nous
de nous faire circoncire
c'est car
dans la compréhension
de la conversion
un peu comme
les catholiques
cette ordonnance
ces sacrements
allaient opérer
quelque part
une espèce
de changement
des statuts
spirituels
dans leur vie
donc si la chose
est compromise
envers les saluts
ou va compromettre
la conception
du salut
on ne doit pas
aller dans cette direction
donc pourquoi
on est en train
de parler sur ça
c'est que parfois
certains chrétiens
vont se retrouver
dans des environnements
où il n'y a pas
une église
qui soit en bonne santé
et ils ne peuvent pas
faire
du baptême
les critères majeurs
pour rester dans
une église
si cette église
pratique les baptêmes
d'enfants
et que vos convictions
sont vraiment profondes
je crois dans
les baptêmes d'enfants
mais qu'en même temps
cette église
est très lâche
par rapport
à la sanctification
à la prédication
de l'évangile
par rapport
à la suffisance
d'écriture
je ne peux pas
en fait
compromettre
toutes ces priorités
qui sont
avant tout
les plus importantes
pour la cause
du roi et oeuvre
juste pour rester accroché
à ma conception
d'une doctrine
qui est importante
mais qui n'est pas
aussi centrale
vous comprenez
et donc c'est important
de voir ça aussi
dans la parole
de Dieu
car parfois
on va devoir
faire quelques exceptions
pour rester dans
une église
en bonne santé
et pour cibler
surtout la promotion
du roi des dieux
et pour finir
cette première section
c'est de faire
la distinction
entre possibilité
et probabilité
donc par exemple
on a parlé
de la fin des temps
donc il y a
certains comme moi
qui croient
qui nous sommes déjà
en train de vivre
les mille ans
et qui sont
profondément convaincus
que l'église
ne va jamais traverser
une espèce
de
comment
rapture
on dit ça en français
un élèvement
sacré
ok
mais
je peux respecter
d'autres positions
différentes
par rapport
à la fin des temps
et je sais que
même si je vous présente
des possibilités différentes
pour certains d'entre vous
c'est surprenant
car vous avez appliqué
une version
et vous êtes accroché
à cette version
mais la réalité
c'est qu'au long
de l'histoire de l'église
vous pouvez avoir
au moins
quatre positions
plutôt traditionnelles
je dirais plutôt trois
et une qui est plutôt nouvelle
et c'est notamment
celle-là
qu'est la nouvelle
dans l'histoire de l'église
mais la réalité
c'est que
même si ces quatre
positions
sont possibles
c'est pas pour dire
que les quatre positions
sont également
probables
et nos responsabilités
entre chrétiens
c'est
d'examiner
par nous-mêmes
dans les écritures
lorsqu'il y a
des possibles divergences
c'est pas pour nous dire
bon on va accepter
n'importe quelle
et on va respecter
également toutes
non
on doit véritablement
aller vers la Bible
et savoir
qu'ils nous seront
rédévables devant Dieu
par rapport
à nos convictions
et chercher
à comprendre
en fait
quelles sont
les possibilités
et quelles sont
que la Bible
puisse supporter
les plus
avec les moins
des trous possibles
dans leur compréhension
et c'est cette invitation
qu'on fait
dans cette leçon
c'est considérer
ensemble
ces deux positions
donc bien sûr
que nous devons
toujours être reconnaissants
que pour plus d'efforts
qu'on fasse
que présenter
une vision
opposée
celle que nous
ne croirons pas
on peut être biaisé
à ne pas présenter
avec les meilleurs
de nos efforts
etc
donc je vous encourage
après pour être
encore plus neutre
à cet égard
d'aller voir
quelques débats
entre des grands
hommes des dieux
qui sont disponibles
comme par exemple
la discussion
entre MacArthur
et Assis Pro
et encore
beaucoup d'autres
mais
je vous présenterai
bien sûr
quelque chose
qui va nous apporter
plutôt dans la direction
de la conviction
baptiste
en essayant
de respecter
la présentation
de la position
de Pédo Baptiste
donc
pour
présenter
de manière concise
la position
Pédo Baptiste
voici
c'est qu'ils présentent
dans leur confession
des fois
cette confession
qui est la base
et la même
qui est la nôtre
sauf
les points doctrinales
par rapport à la gouvernance
d'église
et baptême
et donc là
nous allons retrouver
les baptêmes
et un sacrement
du Nouveau Testament
institué par Jésus Christ
non seulement
pour recevoir
solennellement
les baptiser
dans l'église visible
mais aussi
pour lui être
un signe
et un saut
de
de son
accession
en Christ
de la régénération
de la rémission
des péchés
de son offrande
de lui-même
à Dieu
par Jésus Christ
pour marcher
en nouveauté
des vies
selon l'ordre
même de Christ
ses sacrements
doivent être
perpétués
dans son église
jusqu'à la fin du monde
donc ici
nous pouvons être
d'accord avec tout
ok
c'est un signe
c'est un saut
ok
c'est un symbole
c'est un saut
et ça représente
l'insertion en Christ
ou l'union avec Christ
la régénération
la rémission des péchés
une personne
qui veut souffrir
lui-même à Dieu
souffrir lui-même à Dieu
par Jésus Christ
pour marcher
en nouveauté des vies
etc.
donc là
on est complètement d'accord
là on n'est pas d'accord
c'est notamment
c'est
cette citation
au point C là
il faut baptiser
non seulement
ceux qui font
profession des fins
en Christ
mais aussi
les enfants
des l'un
ou des deux parents
croyants
donc c'est là
où on a
cette divergence
car la réalité
c'est que pour nous
de déclarer ça
après avoir déclaré
ce qu'on a lu avant
c'est une contradiction
comment
appliquer quelque chose
qui vise à sceller
une alliance
lorsque cette alliance
n'est pas encore établie
quels sont les emphases
d'interprétation
pédobaptiste
qui sont reconnues
c'est qu'ils vont
favoriser
surtout
la conception
d'alliance
telle qu'elle a été
établie dans l'Ancien Testament
car c'est vrai
que quand Dieu
a établi cette alliance
dans l'Ancien Testament
notamment
la circoncision
avec Abraham
il a institué
que la circoncision
soit pratiquée
envers les enfants
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
à partir de là
que
l'aspect formel
de cette alliance
des éléments
clairs
de cette alliance
sont présents
c'est à dire
dans leur argument
ils vont dire
les suivants
pour bien comprendre
la conception
d'alliance
nous avons surtout
les présentations bibliques
des alliances
des anciens testaments
et là
les enfants sont inclus
et c'est comme si
tous les éléments
qui composaient
la conception
d'une alliance
dans l'Ancien Testament
devraient se répéter
pour toujours
quelle est la conception
plutôt baptiste
ou credo-baptiste
c'est que oui
nous devons remarquer
qu'il y a
des alliances
dans l'Ancien Testament
qui sont composées
par des éléments
très reconnaissables
dans l'arrangement
d'une alliance
mais les éléments
principaux
de cette alliance
ne sont pas
toujours
connectés
à tous les autres
éléments
qui sont là
pourquoi je dis ça
car même Paul
comme on est en train
de voir en Galacte
lorsqu'il va présenter
cette alliance
qui a été faite
avec Abraham
il va pointer
envers
une alliance
qui a été
ratifiée
avant même
que la circoncision
soit en située
et l'argument
de Paul
c'est que là
c'était la formalisation
majeure
de l'alliance
et il vise
à suggérer
par là
il vise
à démontrer
par là
que la vraie
descendance
d'Abraham
c'est la descendance
de la foi
d'Abraham
car la circoncision
n'avait pas encore eu lieu
ok
et même la descendance
physique
d'Abraham
n'était pas encore là
et donc c'est
une promesse
qui inclut déjà
dans son établissement
fondamental
et formel
ratifié
de cette alliance
quelque chose
qui se passe
avant même
la circoncision
ou la descendance
et donc
pour nous
cet argument
présenté
par les préstétériens
n'est pas valable
déjà dans l'Ancien Testament
et en plus
lorsqu'ils font
une emphase
plutôt
sur l'Ancien Testament
pour après
venir vers la conception
du Nouveau Testament
nous
nous allons réclamer
un principe
d'interprétation
qui est aussi
un principe
d'interprétation
biblique
reconnu
par les préstétériens
partout
que c'est en fait
c'est la priorité
du Nouveau Testament
par rapport
à l'Ancien
il y a deux critères
qui vont être
les principaux
à supporter
notre position
crédobaptiste
le premier
c'est que
les Nouveaux Testament
a de la priorité
pour lancer
des lumières
vers l'Ancien
et non les contraires
et le deuxième
c'est de
faire
que les textes
qui parlent
de manière
les plus explicite
de la Nouvelle Alliance
aient la prééminence
lorsqu'ils définissent
les caractéristiques
de cette Nouvelle Alliance
ok
et donc par exemple
quand on a commencé
par la lecture
de Jérémie
c'est les textes
par excellence
dans l'Ancien Testament
qui mentionnent
l'expression
Nouvelle Alliance
et par là
nous comprenons
clairement
que ce qui caractérise
la Nouvelle Alliance
c'est ce que
Paul Angalat
va appeler
la dispensation
de la foi
c'est quelque chose
qui est tellement
caractérisé
par la circoncision
du coeur
par la présence
de la foi
par l'accomplissement
du Christ
que nous ne voyons
plus de sens
d'avoir une idée
d'une église hybride
composée par des chrétiens
et des non-chrétiens
des personnes
qui sont nées de nouveau
et n'est pas nées de nouveau
car l'emphase
c'est la réalité
de la foi
mais bon
pour résumer
la position
de Pédo Baptiste
on va revenir
sur ses critiques
nous
membres
de son église
en tant que tel
on doit
pardon
à ses ordonnances
et donc
une autre chose
qui est incohérente
c'est qu'ils disent
ils ont droit
à ses ordonnances
mais ils empêchent
que ces enfants
participent
à la sainte-sène
ce qui est très incohérent
et donc
nous allons continuer
et on va marcher
vers
cette conception
quels sont les rapports
et là
c'est ça
qui est au coeur
en fait
selon la manière
dont on détermine
ce qu'est l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance
et quels sont les rapports
entre l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance
c'est là aussi
que nous allons déterminer
qui doit participer
au nom de ces symboles
qui représentent
les participants
de la nouvelle alliance
qui participe
de l'ancienne alliance
de la nouvelle alliance
quels sont les rapports
entre l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance
et quels sont les rapports
entre
une alliance
et plusieurs sous-alliances
avec leurs symboles respectifs
donc
ce qui est commun
aussi
à nouveau
dans toutes les positions
c'est que
si vous vous rappelez bien
Adam et Ève
ok
ils ont été créés
et Dieu a établi
une alliance
d'oeuvres
qu'on appelle
alliance d'oeuvres
mais qui était déjà
une alliance des grâces
pourquoi
car
Dieu n'avait pas
aucune obligation
à donner
Adam et Ève
les privilèges
d'avoir une possibilité
de développer encore plus
de leur position
en mangeant du fruit
de l'arbre de la vie
je n'ai pas tous les temps
pour tout développer
mais bon
ils ont
Dieu
à mener cet accord
cette alliance
envers eux
donc c'est une grâce
de Dieu déjà
mais
c'est correct
d'appeler ça
un pacte d'oeuvre
pourquoi
car eux
ils étaient capables
d'obéir
volontairement
cet accord
donc ils ont rompu
ils se sont mis
dans une condition
d'incapacité
et
des séparations
des dieux
des corruptions
des coupabilités
et d'incapacité
donc séparés
des dieux
à partir de là
ce que nous méritions
c'était tout simplement
l'enfer
ça serait la réponse
juste des dieux
vers l'humanité
et là
Dieu va établir
une alliance
des grâces
et pour plus
que cette alliance
des grâces
dans les développements
de l'histoire
a lieu après la chute
la Bible nous montre
clairement
que cette alliance
des grâces
a été établie
avant la fondation
du monde
donc Dieu
avait déterminé
cette alliance
des grâces
en ayant élu
en peuple
un Jésus Christ
et c'est ces peuples là
qui a été choisi
en Christ
avant la fondation
du monde
comme nous dit
les écritures
c'est ces peuples là
qui va bien sûr
finalement être
les peuples des dieux
les peuples qui va
se convertir
qui va se répentir
qui va avoir la foi
etc
et donc
quand on considère
que cette alliance
des grâces
a été établie
avant la fondation
du monde
nous considérons
aussi la manière
dont Dieu
a manifesté
il a opéré
cette alliance
des grâces
comment cette alliance
qui était planifiée
par Dieu
dans les temps
éternels
s'est déroulée
s'est développée
a été communiquée
par Dieu
de manière didatique
et de manière
effective
donc c'est une seule
alliance des grâces
dans l'Ancien Testament
et dans le Nouveau Testament
sauf que Dieu
a développé
il a porté
le déroulement
de l'accomplissement
de cette alliance
pour que nous arrivons
à la pleine réjouissance
de la réalité
de cette alliance
nous qui sommes
dans la nouvelle alliance
après que Christ
est venu accompli
ici
nous réjouissons
de la plénitude
de cette alliance
mais cette alliance
a été
communiquée
de manière progressive
et développée
par plusieurs types
inférieurs
de cette alliance
donc tous ces types
inférieurs
de cette alliance
des grâces
c'était une progression
c'était une révélation
qu'on appelle progressive
ok
et donc là
on peut penser
à la manière
dont Dieu a établi
d'abord
ce pacte
des grâces
avec Adam et Ève
après la chute
les descendants
de la femme
de la descendance
viendra un
qui va écraser
la tête du serpent
etc
ensuite
il va renouveler
par un pacte
avec Noé
si vous vous rappelez bien
donc ça a lieu aussi
donc les pactes
ce qu'on appelle
nos éthiques
ok
et à chaque fois
Dieu va faire usage
d'un symbole
donc par exemple
l'arc-en-ciel
ensuite
il va appeler
Abraham
et par là
il va établir
cette alliance
et il va utiliser
la circoncision
comme symbole
de cette alliance
et ensuite
on va voir
comment il va développer
ça avec Moïse
avec les symboles
qui étaient
la loi
et plus tard
il va établir
avec David
avec la symbologie
du temple
etc
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
qu'il y a une progression
attention
c'est une progression
double
didatique
ok
il est en train
de communiquer
par quels moyens
nous serons sauvés
quelles conditions
nous sommes
ok
donc
arc-en-ciel
pour plus
qui vous méritez
être puni
il y aura encore
l'espoir
je vais vous préserver
circoncision
vous êtes corrompu
dès la source
vous devez attendre
l'expiation parfaite
car même si vous coupez
dès la source
de la race humaine
ok
de la reproduction humaine
vous n'arrivez jamais
à protéger
vos enfants
de la corruption
du coeur
donc nous n'avons pas
la capacité
donc toujours
important vers l'attente
de quelque chose
qui va encore
s'accomplir
ok
et
de cette manière
la loi vient
pourquoi
à cause des transgressions
pour laisser
de manière encore
plus claire
en fait
quelle est notre
condition
capacité
et qu'est-ce
que celui
qui va accomplir
la loi
à notre place
doit faire
et qu'est-ce
qu'il doit
subir
en termes
de punition
et donc
à nouveau
les besoins
la nécessité
du messie
et une progression
didatique
vis-à-vis
ce qu'il devrait faire
donc c'est double
dans quel sens
c'est didatique
mais c'est aussi
un moyen
de développer
dans l'histoire
l'accomplissement
ok
donc c'est pas
qui est didatique
c'est un moyen
d'accomplissement
donc ces alliances-là
elles étaient en train
de servir
à la préservation
quelque part
du peuple juif
car
et là c'est
la clé pour nous
à travers
les peuples juifs
il vient
l'instruction
de par quel moyen
tous les êtres humains
peuvent trouver
les saluts
mais ça vient aussi
un descendant
biologique
qui doit venir
pour accomplir
la loi
et les saluts
les fondements
de saluts
et donc ce qui est
important à remarquer
c'est de voir
en fait
que même si
on a eu
et on a
une seule
alliance des grâces
dès Adam
jusqu'au retour
de Christ
nous avons en fait
deux administrations
générales différentes
une qui est composée
par plusieurs
pactes
ok
et qui est plus
caractérisée
par l'attente
de l'accomplissement
et pourquoi
dans ces cadres
c'est légitime
que ceux qui participent
à cette alliance
ou cette dispensation
de l'alliance
les peuples
des dieux
soient hybrides
pourquoi
c'est légitime
que dans l'ancien testament
ces peuples
soient composés
non seulement
que des vrais croyants
mais aussi
d'une descendance
physique
biologique
ça c'est la grande
question pour nous
et pourquoi
car dans l'ancienne
alliance
les rôles
didatiques
instructives
d'Israël
c'est comme si
Israël
qui était une nation
réelle
elle était aussi
une espèce
de théâtre
des dieux
d'une nation
qui se rapporte
envers dieux
religieusement
et qui est
soit punie
soit bénie
et c'est là
déviant
une école
élémentaire
de la foi
pour toutes les nations
vous êtes avec moi
donc c'est tout à fait
légitime
comme la Bible
a toujours démontré
comme les descendants
doivent venir
d'entre les juifs
cette nation
doit être préservée
et comme cette nation
doit enseigner
plusieurs choses
spirituelles
à toutes les nations
cette nation
sera aussi préservée
et donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe
en Israël
c'est que
la double nature
de ces peuples
est par descent
c'était un descent
des dieux
dans cette ancienne
alliance
que les peuples
d'Israël
soient composés
des chrétiens
et des non-chrétiens
les restes
chrétiens
un petit nombre
mais une nation
biologique
ethnique
qui avait un rôle
qui était temporel
et qui était temporaire
et qui était important
pour communiquer
les saluts
donc pourquoi
la nature
du peuple
de l'Ancien Testament
est double
c'est qu'Arduavès
c'est des saints
double pour Israël
par contre
nous pouvons reconnaître
par là
que c'est légitime
de baptiser
ou pas de baptiser
mais de circoncire
les enfants
dans les cadres
de l'Ancien
de la Dispensation
car même si
un enfant
n'est pas
spirituellement
converti
n'est pas
régénéré
et ne sera
jamais sauvé
comme la plupart
de ces peuples
la réalité
c'est qu'il participait
à un descent
temporel
et temporaire
destiné par Dieu
et par là
en fait
c'était légitime
de circoncire
les enfants
car nous devons
préserver cette nation
cette nation
doit être visible
pour toutes les nations
pour jouer son rôle
et dès cette nation
les crises
viendront
sauf que quand on arrive
dans la nouvelle alliance
nous n'avons plus
par des saints divants
aucun sens
d'avoir
une église
hybride
quel est l'essence
d'insérer
dans l'église
ou d'émettre
l'emphase
sur quelque chose
qu'on puisse apprendre
ou attendre
par rapport
aux enfants
qui soit
liés
à la réalité
de l'église
qui réjouit déjà
de son plan
d'accomplissement
le Messie
il est déjà venu
le mur des séparations
est déjà tombé
les peuples
des dieux
et toutes les lettres
du Nouveau Testament
pointent
par les faits
quelle est la notion
ou l'essence
de pratiquer
de la discipline
ecclésiale
par exemple
pour être sûr
que les personnes
qui participent
par la sainte scène
soient des vrais croyants
si nous pourrions
avoir une église
qui soit par des saints
une église hybride
et donc la réalité
c'est qu'une église
est imparfaite
dans sa capacité
de juger
d'évaluer
qui sont les vrais sauvés
mais par des saints
cette église
est commissionnée
par Christ
à baptiser
ceux qui croient
et exclusivement
et c'est ça
les rôles de l'église
à cet égard
donc
cette conception
d'alliance
elle est
j'ai déjà pas mal
avancé des choses
mais
elle est très riche
très généreuse
à plusieurs égards
je vais juste présenter
je n'aurai pas
le temps
de tout développer
mais on peut
revenir après
mais
quelles sont
les objections
générales
envers les pédobaptèmes
les premiers
c'est les divorces
entre les signes
qui est la réalité
j'ai déjà parlé de ça
donc c'est intéressant
car les débuts
de ma révision
de mes convictions
presbytériennes
de mon origine
après je me suis converti
dans l'église presbytérienne
et donc
c'était les moments
où je devrais baptiser
ma fille
et je n'étais pas
du tout en paix
et je me suis dit
mais quelle est l'essence
qu'elle participe
et ce n'est pas pour dire
que ça c'est l'argument
principal
l'argument il faut
qu'il soit biblique
mais la crainte
dans mon coeur c'est
mais quel est
quel sera son profit
ok
de cette cérémonie
cérémonie
si elle n'a pas
des mémoires
des consciences
de ce qu'elle a vécu
donc par exemple
si on pense
à la circoncision
c'est quelque chose
qui est très
auto-explicatoire
non
auto-explicatif
comment on dit ça
en français
voilà
si un enfant
qui va grandir
avec cette marque
il sera toujours là
et il va apprendre
en fait
pourquoi
quel est l'essence
qu'est-ce que ça signifie
et donc
il y aura toujours
un rôle didatique pour ça
mais Christ
il a choisi
un symbole
qui ne marque pas
physiquement
car cette marque
par des saints
est une marque spirituelle
et donc l'eau
elle représente
les lavages spirituels
mais la réalité
de la lavage spirituel
est toujours en train
de raisonner
avec les baptêmes
qu'on a pratiqués
ou qu'on va pratiquer
et donc la réalité
c'est que
si les baptêmes
qui ne laissent
aucune marque
peut avoir
une utilité
à cet égard
c'est un peu
incohérent
et surtout
en fait
les rôles
des signes
qui avaient du sens
dans l'enfant
de l'Ancien Testament
car il était
véritablement marqué
comme les peuples
littérales
temporelles
desquelles
les messies
seraient issus
même biologiquement
mais par contre
il n'y a plus
de sens
qu'un enfant
soit marqué
et n'est pas marqué
en même temps
car ça ne laisse
pas des marques
sans qu'on ait
une assurance
pleine
qui est
sa conversion
aura lieu
et ça va porter
une autre implication
mais bon
les divorces
entre les signes
et la réalité
si la fonction
du signe
c'est de sceller
c'est de rassurer
de ma foi
comment je peux
être rassuré
si la foi
n'est pas encore là
et comment
l'Église pourrait
confirmer quelque chose
qui n'est pas encore là
le point 2
c'est la mise en risque
de la distinction
entre naître
des chrétiens
et naître
des nouveaux
donc là
c'est un risque
qui n'est pas forcément
dans tous les cas
ce qui va se passer
dans la mentalité
des pédobaptistes
mais il y a un risque
que des personnes
se reposent
dans le fait
que l'enfant
est baptisé
et qu'ils attendent
de manière un peu
responsable
qu'ils cela s'accomplissent
donc cette tromperie
responsable
de la plupart
des églises
ou des états
protestants
qui sont
ce qu'on appelle
nominaux
ils considèrent
que la population
est chrétienne
tout simplement
quand ils sont nés
ils sont baptisés
ils sont comptés
par là
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
en fait
c'est important
de faire la distinction
et une autre chose
qu'il faut remarquer
c'est que
dans l'Ancien Testament
peu importe
combien de générations
ont été
quelque part
corrompues
le fait
qu'ils soient
descendants
biologiques
d'Israël
faisaient
qu'ils soient
les peuples
de la promesse
quelque part
donc peu importe
si mon enfant
mon petit-fils
et mon
un réa
petit-fils
si on peut dire
comme ça
que Dieu
nous délivre
de ça
mais
s'ils ne sont pas
pure
convertis
mais si je suis
un descendant
des juifs
d'ici
quelques générations
vers l'avant
quelqu'un
reviendra
à avoir
cette importance
biologique
d'être marqué
c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne perd jamais
indépendamment
de la piété
de ces personnes-là
par contre
c'est incohérent
en fait
que ceux qui réclament
que les enfants
des chrétiens
doivent être baptisés
réclament juste
pour la première génération
ils ne disent pas
en fait
on va continuer
à baptiser
par exemple
demander à une personne
dans la rue
est-ce qu'il y a
un protestant
dans ta famille
oui j'ai entendu parler
qu'il y a 5 générations
en arrière
il y avait un chrétien
donc toi
tu dois baptiser
ton enfant
etc
non ils vont dire
que c'est l'enfant
des chrétiens
qui doit être baptisé
mais pas forcément
toute sa descendance
comme dans les cas
de l'Ancien Testament
c'est une autre incohérence
liée à ça
donc toi
supposé à tort
que Dieu forme
les peuples
de la nouvelle alliance
de la même manière
qu'il formait
les peuples
de l'Ancienne Alliance
donc je vous ai déjà
parlé sur ça
en fait
les peuples
de l'Ancienne Alliance
étaient formés
par biologie
avec ses rôles temporels
mais dans la nouvelle alliance
la manière
dont la Bible
montre très clair
comment les peuples
de Dieu
sont formés
c'est
répandant ses foi
ok
point 4
objection 4
c'est
supposé à tort
que l'église du Nouveau Testament
est hétérogène
par des saints
je vous ai déjà
expliqué ces points
nous savons
que l'église
du Nouveau Testament
elle est
homogène
par des saints
elle est formée
des chrétiens
autre point
c'est de négliger
les différences cruciales
entre circoncision
et baptême
donc c'est très intéressant
en fait
la plupart des passages
bibliques
qui nous parlent
de baptême
en faisant une comparaison
avec la circoncision
va ponter
envers les baptêmes
comme étant
la circoncision
du coeur
c'est pour démontrer
le fait
que cette nouvelle
circoncision
est différente
elle confirme
les prophéties
de l'Ancien Testament
par rapport
à la nouvelle alliance
qui nous présentent
la circoncision
du coeur
c'est à dire
la réalité
de la foi
et là
je vous encourage
après à lire
les passages
et ça risque aussi
de disqualifier
la conception biblique
des promesses
par inefficacité
qu'est-ce que je veux dire
par là
c'est que si par exemple
un enfant était circoncis
dans l'Ancien Testament
cela signifiait
que les promesses
temporelles de Dieu
envers cette ethnie
auraient lieu
pour toujours
et Dieu
n'a jamais failli
même l'apôtre Paul
lorsqu'il va présenter
les cas
du fait
qui nie tout Israël
biologique
est l'Israël des dieux
est l'Israël croyant
il va les faire
en laissant très clair
que les desseins
des dieux
ou les promesses
n'ont jamais manqué
et que ces promesses
étaient toujours dirigées
surtout aux principes
spirituels
ok
et même
quelques promesses
faites à Israël
de manière temporelle
auront toujours lieu
pour toujours
mais la réalité
c'est intéressant
à remarquer
c'est qu'à partir
du moment
où je pratique
les baptêmes
d'enfants
en considérant
que c'est une promesse
automatique
certaine
là
je vais changer
la conception
biblique des promesses
car la conception
est infaillible
et si je sais
que certains enfants
et certains chrétiens
ne se convertissent pas
je suis en train
de compromettre
de disqualifier
même la conception
biblique des promesses
je n'ai pas le droit
d'agir
comme s'il s'agissait
d'une promesse
car la nature
des promesses
publiques
c'est infaillibilité
donc il faut faire
attention à ça
et donc
je vous encourage
après à lire
les textes cités
et je vais juste
faire quelques réponses
rapides
au contre-argument
pédobaptiste
donc les baptêmes
des familles entières
c'est un argument
qu'ils vont démontrer
dans les écritures
c'est que je vous encourage
à remarquer
dans ces passages
c'est que
dans les passages
où les baptêmes
des enfants
sont mentionnés
nous n'avons pas
beaucoup plus
d'informations
mais si nous considérons
un peu plus
d'informations
il y a
les présupposés
que l'évangile
a été prêché
a été compris
et ces personnes-là
ont été baptisées
donc nous n'avons pas
d'informations précises
par rapport à l'âge
de ces personnes
mais nous avons
des indices
qui pointent envers
la capacité
de compréhension
il y a des passages
où ça dit
qu'ils se sont réjouis
d'avoir entendu
la parole
et ils sont baptisés
et donc voilà
premier argument
après
l'appel
à obéir
aux parents
croyants
dans les seigneurs
et la référence
aux enfants
des croyants
en tant que sang
et donc là
en fait
c'est pas forcément
de suggérer
qu'ils sont devenus
sang
tout simplement
quand ils étaient
enfants des chrétiens
mais ça suggère
qu'à un moment donné
ils ont été convertis
par l'influence
de leurs parents
ok
ça ne veut pas dire
forcément
qu'il s'agit
d'une sanctification
par accomplissement
des promesses
ou du baptême
la circoncision
d'Abraham
en tant que confirmation
!
et sa justification
par la foi
donc là
je vous ai déjà parlé
sur ces ponts
la réalité
c'est qu'Abraham
a été l'objet
de la grâce
de Dieu
et du salut
avant même
que la circoncision
soit instituée
et
l'argument
qu'il dit
et qu'il déréjetait
les pédobaptèmes
c'est d'expulser
les enfants
de l'église
c'est pas ça
dans les contextes
baptistes
on essaye
d'encourager
la responsabilité
que nous avons
envers les enfants
de notre communauté
pour les évangéliser
de garder une relation
proche envers eux
d'attendre vraiment
que Dieu puisse
les convertir
de faire confiance
de manière optimiste
à ce que Dieu peut faire
à travers nos vies
et dans leur vie
surtout si nous sommes
responsables
dans leur éducation
chrétienne
mais
cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on veut expulser
les enfants
de l'église
même car
si
les chrétiens
pardon
même si les enfants
des chrétiens
ils sont baptisés
ils sont considérés
comme membres
de l'église
et quand ils commencent
à se porter
de manière très rebelle
très mauvaise
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
pratiquer l'excommunication
selon la Bible
et donc
c'est très
ça devient vraiment
très incohérent
de garder
ce type
de participation
hybride
dans la communauté
et point 5
réjeter
les pédobaptismes
c'est
dérompre
l'unité
des écritures
et du plan
des rédemptions
des dieux
donc là
c'est les points
que je vous ai
expliqués
le plus
pendant ces cours
bien sûr
qu'il y a des questions
qui peuvent rester
on peut revenir
un argument
qui revient toujours
c'est acte
chapitre 2
et c'est juste
pour dire
que les critères
d'interprétation
de ces passages
la pentecôte
la prédication
des pierres
c'est pour vous
et pour vos enfants
et les préditériens
aiment s'arrêter là
mais la réalité
c'est
c'est pour vous
et pour vos enfants
et
et pour
pour tous ceux
qu'il plaît
à l'éternel
d'appeler
c'est
on va
on va ouvrir
les passages
qu'on a lu au départ
verset 39
acte 2
car la promesse
est pour vous
pour vos enfants
et pour tous ceux
qui sont au loin
en aussi grand nombre
que les seigneurs
notre Dieu
les appellera
et donc à la fin
la détermination
du passage
c'est déjà
tous les passages
bibliques
des baptêmes
où nous avons
plus d'informations
nous voyons
que la répentance
et la fin
a été exercée
ils ont été baptisés
après la conversion
et en plus
les passages
où on voit
les enfants mentionnés
nous voyons
qu'il y a toujours
des indices
très contrôlateurs
ici
en disant
dans un aussi grand nombre
c'est à dire
les nombres exacts
c'est les nombres exacts
que notre Dieu
les appellera
donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
ces remarques
qui sont
les